hello readers you know that feeling when
you're reading and you see a word you've
never seen before and you don't really
know how to figure out what it means
well that's what we're talking about
today strategies for figuring out new
words through context
you're always going to be encountering
new words at the time of this recording
i'm 31 and i run into new and confusing
words every day i read a lot and it's
always a fun challenge to run into words
like i don't know glabrous or limbed or
nakrius i know a lot about language and
even i have trouble figuring out what
those words mean on their own so it's
important to rely on context the
language that surrounds the word
let's say you're reading a text and you
come across a sentence that has a word
in it you don't recognize
here's a bit from a passage about the
famous chimpanzee researcher jane
goodall
jane goodall arrived at tanzania's gombe
stream national park in 1960. she was
considered somewhat unconventional among
other animal researchers after all she
had not yet been to college
so let's pause on unconventional what
does that word mean
well let me give you some ideas that's
the memory aid i use to keep it straight
ideas it stands for
inference definition example antonin
synonym i-d-e-a-s
ideas
which are all different kinds of context
clues every word will have a different
context so you might need to vary your
approach
the way this snippet is written let's
try inference first then i'll rewrite
the sentence a few times to show you the
other methods okay the i and ideas
inference we can draw conclusions from
the context if we don't know what
unconventional means we can take a look
at the rest of the sentence or other
nearby sentences to figure it out being
unconventional seems to make goodall
different from other researchers she
hadn't yet been to college which implies
that the rest of them had that doesn't
give us a full answer but it does tell
us that she's different somehow so i
think that unconventional might mean
different than what is normal and
because i'm making an inference about
this word's meaning i want to keep an
eye out for it in other places to see if
i can confirm or revise that working
definition later
d definition
context clues like these will just give
you the definition of the word in
question so a good example of that would
be she was considered somewhat
unconventional among other animal
researchers she hadn't been to college
yet and this made her different and
unexpected
different and unexpected is a great
definition for the word unconventional
this style of context clue occurs when
the author expects a word to be
unfamiliar to you and builds in a guide
for you right there in the text the e in
ideas stands for example and this is
somewhere between inference and
definition if the author describes
goodall as unconventional they'll go on
to talk about something unconventional
that goodall did
she was considered somewhat
unconventional among animal researchers
for one thing she hadn't been to college
yet so this is very similar to that
initial sentence except for the
transition phrase for one thing which is
a way to set up examples
antonym an antonym is a word whose
meaning is the opposite of another word
like how night is the opposite of day or
how love is the opposite of hate so if
there's an example in the text of what
jane goodall was not
we can use that to figure out what she
was
so let's say the passage said goodall
was unconventional she didn't conform
and she wasn't ordinary there we have
two antonyms and our answer
similarly synonym just means write
another word with the same meaning
similar to a definition
jane goodall was unconventional she was
a non-conformist she went against the
grain you can see that i had to rewrite
the sentences each time to apply to each
context clue strategy which shows me
that you won't find all five context
clues every time you need to search for
a word's meaning you need to find the
approach that makes the most sense in
context see what i did there
and failing that you can always look up
an unfamiliar word in a dictionary i
love to do that i think that's great but
i also feel a sense of victory when i
correctly figure out what a new word
means when i've put it together from
context and maybe if i'm still curious i
look it up later and then i turn out to
be right and i'm all like victory at c i
did it
oh and if you were curious glabris means
smooth and hairless like a leaf or the
skin of a frog nacreous means shiny and
rainbow colored like the inside of an
oyster shell
and to limb something means to draw the
outline of or to be highlighted in light
you can learn anything
david out